[Musik]
ein 48 jähriger wurde festgenommen im
zusammenhang mit dem mord in einem mann
aus cardiff am montag dem zur last
gelegt der mann soll seinen besten
freund mit einem hammer erschlagen und
ihm bargeld und drogen im wert von
mehreren 1000 pfund gestohlen haben der
mann erlitt einen 23 fachen schädelbruch
die partie soll die leiche in einen
teppich gewickelt in sein auto gelegt
und dann angezündet haben um alle
beweise zu vernichten
dem richter war und 30 jahre haft für
dieses verbrechen zu wenig statt dessen
sollte hacker die den rest seines lebens
im gefängnis verbringen
er findet wie lautet ihr urteil
lebenslänglich das ganze leben
was heißt das das heißt ich würde im
gefängnis sterben
aber das ist völliger irrsinn wie soll
man jemanden wie mich da noch
kontrollieren
weil sie nichts zu verlieren haben nein
nichts wenn ich die zwei beamten hier um
bringe was ich nicht tue aber was würden
sie dann machen
ich bin eine gefahr für die beiden und
auch für sie
ja
die zelle es sicher schön groß ja riesig
beschissen groß
wie ist die erste eindruck
folglich seien winzig ob sich das hier
wohl je wie ein zuhause anführen wird
niemals
[Musik]
er trieb rissen in der englischen
grafschaft leicestershire hier sitzen
mehr verurteilte mörder ein als in jeder
anderen britischen haftanstalt von den
700 gefangenen verbüßen 85 prozent eine
lebenslange strafe wegen mordes
ich bin hier weil ich meinen besten
freund im streit getötet habe
vor mir klar wurde was ich tat wirkte
ich sie schon
[Musik]
es war eine riesen sauerei alles war
voller blut meine kleidung der boden
direkt nach ihrer ankunft werden die
lebenslang verurteilten von einem team
forensischer psychologen überwacht
wir hatten hier schon religiös
motivierte mörder und auftragskiller
männer ohne vorstrafe die plötzlich ihre
frau getötet haben oder auch alkoholiker
die an einem samstagabend im vollrausch
zu mördern wurden manche sind sehr
gebildet manche sind fachleute
oder millionäre die ihre
geschäftspartner getötet haben wenn ich
in der zeitung von einem mord lese in
einen grausamen details denke ich nicht
geht sondern frage mich nur wann der
täter wohl hier eintrifft
als ich aus dem klub kam hatte ich nur
einen gedanken
ich muss jetzt jemanden umbringen ganz
egal wen es
spielt überhaupt keine rolle
ich wollte noch etwas essen in einem
imbiss zu einem dönerladen
saß eine frau neben mir
wir kamen ins gespräch und ich dachte
die ganze zeit nur ich muss sie
umbringen ich muss sie zu einem
nahegelegenen feld bringen und töten sie
konnte nicht ahnen was ich vorhatte sie
suchte wohl eine
übernachtungsmöglichkeit oder wollte
noch was trinken
ich weiß es nicht mehr genau
nach ungefähr 20 minuten gingen wir
zusammen raus
richtung feld
dort habe ich sie dann getötet und mich
anschließend gestellt
wie auch schauen müssen nicht alle
lebenslänglichen zwingend den rest ihrer
tage im gefängnis verbringen der richter
bestimmt im urteil eine mindesthaftzeit
der richter kann zum beispiel 15 20 oder
auch zwölf jahre festlegen und die sind
dann jeweils das absolute minimum an
zeit die der verurteilte im gefängnis
verbringen muss
[Musik]
um am ende der mindesthaftzeit entlassen
zu werden müssen die gefangenen die
verantwortlichen überzeugen dass sie
keine gefahr mehr für die öffentlichkeit
darstellen alles was du tust wird
beobachtet und analysiert
alles
wenn ich und traf uns jetzt auf dem flur
prügeln dann kommt das in die akte und
hängt uns ewig nach sehr zu unserem
schaden
für uns hat die öffentliche sicherheit
höchste priorität
wir entlassen niemanden den man nicht
gefahrlos untermenschen lassen kann
[Musik]
das hier bei euch für meinen ältesten
sohn er wünscht sich einen mythischen
schild aber er hat mir nicht gesagt wie
so etwas aussieht
also denke ich mir einfach was aus
er besteht aus streichhölzern und alten
obstkisten ich sitze jetzt seit rund 18
monaten daran
dass sie ist pegasus
wie viele streichhölzer stecken darin
ungefähr 300 etwa 50 an einem flügel die
drachen kommen hier nach oben für die
unterseite habe ich noch keine idee aber
ich habe ja noch ein bisschen zeit wie
alt waren sie als sie herkam
41 da bekam ich lebenslänglich
ich bin hier weil ich meinen besten
freund im streit getötet habe
am 24 januar 2005 diesen tag werde ich
niemals vergessen nie
ich ging zu gary um drogen zu kaufen
der hat mich um ein paar gramm
beschissen und wir diskutiert
[Musik]
na ja geht
lief alles aus dem ruder
ich holte ein messer aus der küche und
brachte ihn um
ich bin einfach durchgedreht sagte noch
scheiß drauf
ich habe gehrys leben beendet
ich weiß ehrlich nicht warum ich das
getan habe
ich habe die drogen dann nicht mal
mitgenommen ich bin einfach gegangen
wenn ich die zeit zurückdrehen könnte
geht nicht
keine chance
[Musik]
es wäre zu schön wo ich
wusste schon immer dass ich ein problem
habt dass ich nicht normal bin in der
schule war ich eher ein außenseiter
ab und zu hatte ich mal einen freund
aber nie besonders lange in der schule
habe ich mich oft geprügelt die leute
haben gesagt ich sei ein netter kerl und
sehr intelligent aber ich hätte mich
einfach nicht im griff
ich wusste mit mir stimmt irgendwas
nicht
ich wollte ja wie alle anderen sein aber
ich passte einfach nicht dazu
[Musik]
im gefängnis wird bei schauen das
asperger syndrom diagnostiziert eine
form von autismus
betroffene sind oft hoch begabt mit
zehn oder elf jahren konnte ich aufgaben
lösen die für kinder in dem alter
normalerweise zu schwer sind
ich galt als mathematisches talent
im gefängnis habe ich dann den
schulabschluss gemacht
und jetzt schließe ich gerade mein
mathematik studium ab
ich will mich nicht rausreden nach dem
motto ich hab asperger und darum habe
ich diese tat begangen aber
die störung hatte schon einfluss auf
mein leben und manchmal frage ich mich
wie es wohl verlaufen wäre wenn ich kein
asperger hätte und wie die anderen wäre
vielleicht würde ich jetzt im büro
sitzen hätte eine frauen zwei kinder
hätte alltägliche streitereien und
irgendwann kennen die scheidung ist
ebenso oft läuft da draußen
schon wurde wegen totschlags verurteilt
weil das gericht von verminderter
schuldfähigkeit aus ging festgelegt
wurde eine mindesthaftzeit von nur neun
jahren aber auch nach zwölf jahren gilt
er als zu gefährlich um entlassen zu
werden
könnten sie draußen wieder in
schwierigkeiten geraten
ich glaube nicht
aber im gefängnis habe ich gelernt dass
man nie genau weiß was alles passieren
kann
[Musik]
der großteil der gefangenen im gare
trieb rissen verbüßt lebenslange
freiheitsstrafe verurteilte mörder
bleiben meist mindestens 15 jahre in
haft manche aber auch sehr viel länger
mir war nie klar was für einen
unterschied weiß spieler bei der wäsche
ausmachen kann früher habe ich so was
nie gekauft aber dann habe ich hier drin
ausprobiert und konnte nicht fassen wie
weit die wäsche damit wird
seitdem bin ich quasi süchtig danach
chris wurde 2008 wegen mordes verurteilt
mit zwei anderen hat er auf der straße
einen mann überfallen und zu tode
getreten
hier meine bescheidene hütte mein bett
schön gemütlich das nackenkissen ist
ganz bequem
hier darf man nicht aufhängen ist ja
klar wieso
haben sie den film die verurteilten
gesehen da hing ein großes poster an der
wand um ein riesiges loch zu verdecken
die wand muss also frei bleiben das sind
meine zwei wellensittiche der blaue
heißt stanley der gelbe giotto
ich lasse sie so oft wie möglich raus
sie sollen nicht nur im käfig hocken
noch dazu in einer zelle das sind
freiheitsliebende geschöpfe sie sollen
fliegen und frei sein
paarungswillige ist geht es zwischen den
beiden heiß her ziemlich gemein mit
anzusehen wie die zwei sich vergnügen
während ich hier 23 jahre eingesperrt
bin
wie alle lebenslänglichen muss auch
chris eine mindest haftstrafe absitzen
in seinem fall sind das 23 jahre
der richter sagte nach 23 jahren im
gefängnis können sie bewährung
beantragen dollar an tragen das heißt
nicht dass ich mit 52 ein freier mann
sein werde die überlegen dann nur ob sie
mich raus lassen als ich das hörte
dachte ich wow ich werde 52 sein wenn
ich bewährung beantragen kann ich war 27
als ich herkam und bin dann 52
diese erkenntnis hat mich umgehauen dass
das hier bis auf weiteres erst mal mein
leben ist
und alles klar kann es losgehen viele
gefangene belastet es schwer dass sie
nicht wissen ob sie jemals wieder
freikommen
ich kenne chris schon lange verletzt
sich selbst an manchen tagen tut erst
einmal von anderen zwei oder drei mal
wie sieht's aus
da wo die gabel drinsteckt
die gabel
er sagt er hätte sich letzte woche ein
stück von einer plastikgabel in die
wunde gesteckt
schon beim arzt damit der das aus der
wunde rausholen kann
aber er hat nichts gefunden
kein spüren sie das reststück
weil sie wissen wo es ist ja
wo soll es denn stecken hier irgendwo
sie haben es durch diese wunde
hochgeschoben nein durch die hier diese
er da ist ein loch
es ist ziemlich ernst er hat kaum noch
gefühl in seinem linken arm wo er die
meisten verletzungen hat er fängt jetzt
schon mit dem rechten arm an weil der
linke so kaputt ist er weiß dass er ihn
sogar verlieren könnte
das ist seine art mit stress umzugehen
und da findet vieles in seinem leben
sehr stressig
[Musik]
die gefangenen in betrieb reisen sind
nur nachts und mittags in der zelle
eingeschlossen
den rest des tages haben sie freizeit
manche lernen andere machen sport zu
oder arbeiten
gefangene die arbeiten verdienen 12
pfund pro woche geld für luxusgüter wie
süßigkeiten turnschuhe oder videospiele
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nicht alle gefangenen halten sich an die
regeln das sicherheitsteam hat den
hinweis bekommen dass ein paar häftlinge
illegal alkohol herstellen puzzle den
man auch gut nennt
die sagen der flüssigkeit dazu weil
nicht ganz klar ist was genau das
eigentlich ist wir wissen selbst nicht
das zeug auch schon mal gemacht und dem
ich mit heißem wasser
dazu getan habe und den orangensaft den
wer täglich kriegen dann wartet man bis
es gärt und trinkt es
[Applaus]
lebenslänglich sind eine ganze weile
hier dementsprechend viel zeit haben sie
sich dummheiten auszudenken je länger
ein gefangener hier ist desto leichter
fällt es ihm uns auf trab zu halten
[Musik]
darunter ist was
nicht gerade wenig ziemlich viel ja das
reicht für den ganzen flur
jetzt erwägt ist
ja das ist eindeutig
wie viel alkohol ist er drin 60 80
prozent
das ist ein katz und maus spiel
haben wir damit durch können wir uns
betrinken
ansonsten sitzen wir eben auf dem
trockenen
der schlüssel wurde in der zelle von
martin mcguinness gefunden der
mundöffnung und umdrehen
er muss zu einer richterlichen anhörung
einmal die gefangenen
26 ak okay es geht um diese tüte
was glauben sie was da drin ist
sie wissen dass es verboten ist so etwas
in der zelle herzustellen oder zu hunger
okay das ist das sechste mal dass bei
ihnen alkohol gefunden wurde ist ihnen
bewusst dass sich das nachteilig auf den
zeitpunkt ihrer freilassung auswirken
wird gehen wir martin
martin bekommt zur strafe 21 tage
isolationshaft
aber sehr viel schwerer wiegt dass der
vorfall gegen entsprechen wird wenn es
um seine entlassung geht
wie schmeckt das
eklig
erzählen sie mal wie das geht kann sich
ja nicht dann eben nicht
wie ist das wenn sie das intus haben
furchtbar ganz schlimm dann geht's
richtig ab viele gefangene hier werden
während ihre straftat alkoholisiert sein
sollten keinesfalls was trinken dann
werden sie gewalttätig
hier war ich sehr aggressiv aber jetzt
wo ich älter geworden bin habe ich mich
besser im griff nur lebenslängliche die
bewiesen haben dass sie keine gefahr
mehr für die öffentlichkeit darstellen
dürfen nach verbüßung der mindeststrafe
raus das psychologenteam beurteilt sie
regelmäßig war ihnen damals bewusst dass
sie auch anders hätte handeln können
ich wollte schon als kind ein verbrecher
werden
ich habe mich dafür entschieden obwohl
ich wusste dass es falsch war
ich wusste dass ich damit andere
verletzen
hier geht es um aufrichtige reue
sollen sich wirklich in die lage ihrer
opfer hineinversetzen und deren gefühle
nachempfinden
mein opfer hat überlebt aber das gesicht
das er tagtäglich im spiegel sieht ist
für immer entstellt so durchlebt er
ständig aufs neue was ich ihm angetan
habe
psychologen haben wir das sagen
sollte es besser ihrer meinung sein egal
worum es geht
sonst kommst du hier nie raus sie sind
das ticket in die freiheit ganz einfach
sie haben unheimlich viel macht
eine unterschrift von denen und schon
sitzt man zehn jahre länger
diese gespräche haben meine sicht auf
die dinge verändert ich muss mir
eingestehen ja das war ich der diese
person angegriffen hat und es war falsch
die meisten fühlen sich furchtbar wegen
ihrer tat
sie würden es gern wieder gutmachen
kontakt zum opfer oder dessen
angehörigen aufnehmen
einfach irgendetwas tun um wieder gut zu
machen was sie angerichtet haben aber
natürlich gibt es auch die die überhaupt
nichts bereuen
[Musik]
auf meiner brust ist ein walisischer
drache der eine englische bulldogge von
hinten nimmt
und hier unten steht nur für dicke beute
ich wollte noch viel mehr tattoos aber
dann wurde ich verknackt
das war's
2006 habe ich als saisonarbeiter in
schottland gearbeitet und dort
supermärkte und baumärkte eingerichtet
und wie war der job
ist gut im grunde wie bezahlt der urlaub
nach drei einsätzen wurde ich zum
teamleiter befördert das war cool weil
ich dann der boss war und natürlich für
die wenigste arbeit das meiste geld
kassierte
es war samstag ein ganz normaler tag
mitten im sommer alle waren gut drauf
und heiß aufs match england spielt die
in der fußball wm gegen portugal
es kam zum elfmeterschießen
fast alle feierten england an ich war
aber für portugal ich bin walliser ich
hab was gegen england
deren team ist dann im elfmeterschießen
rausgeflogen
die leute treten fast durch vor wut aber
ich habe mich gefreut wie ein bekloppter
ich hatte richtig spaß
dann ging ich mit ein paar kollegen
zurück ins hotel und holte noch 15
flaschen bier für uns
wir waren in feierlaune
die nacht war noch jung
5 ging ich mir zwei jungs raus um eine
zu rauchen
die beiden gerieten wegen irgendwas in
streit keine ahnung worum es ging ich
bin aufgestanden um dazwischen zu gehen
ich habe den einen zur seite geschoben
und gesagt er soll da stehen bleiben
dann drehte ich mich zum anderen um mit
ihm zu reden
stattdessen schlug ich einfach auf ihn
ein immer wieder immer wieder
mit welchem ergebnis
mit dem ergebnis dass ich ihn umgebracht
hat und
wie
ich habe ihn geschlagen getreten sind
auf ihm herumgetrampelt
ungefähr anderthalb stunden lang
dann habe ich seinen leblosen körper ins
gebüsch geschleift und da versteckt
[Musik]
überall war wahnsinnig viel blut meine
kleidung der boden alles war voller blut
[Musik]
ich hatte kein gutes gefühl dabei aber
auch kein schlechtes es fühlte sich
irgendwie normal an hätte sich gut
angefühlt könnte ich mich daran erinnern
und hätte es sich schlecht angefühlt
hätte ich aufgehört
es fühlte sich einfach normal an
es scheint sie gar nicht zu berühren
woran liegt das
gute frage
hat doch keine ahnung
wollen sie die tat
also in gewisser hinsicht ja
andererseits habe ich hier im gefängnis
viel gelernt mich qualifiziert
ohne meine tat hätte ich diese chance ja
sonst nicht gehabt
vorher kam hatte ich überhaupt nichts
vorzuweisen
hier habe ich unterricht bekommen in
geografie biologie
und mathematik und haben mich in
englisch verbessert ich kann jetzt
besser lesen und schreiben
der menschen empfinden einfach kein
mitgefühl sie sind nicht hämisch oder
wollen ihre tat herunterspielen
sie fühlen das einfach nicht
das ändert sich auch nicht wenn man sie
75 jahre lang einsperren
[Musik]
weihnachten im betrieb rissen der tag
beginnt wie jeder andere morgens um acht
und 15 werden die zellen geöffnet viele
häftlinge wollen mit ihren angehörigen
telefonieren
[Applaus]
hallo vor weihnachten mensch
ist mein junge da
weihnachten mein sohn
sagt den anderen kindern auch vor
weihnachten von mir
ja klar sind sie völlig aus dem häuschen
ist doch normal an weihnachten
oh
ihr bricht mir das verdammte herz
so habe ich liebe euch ich die haut mich
um erstmals
o
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alle bereiten jahrestage und geburtstage
das sind die schlimmsten tage echt
deprimierend aber da muss man durch geht
nicht anders
willkommen zum weihnachtsessen
aber sie wie geht's gut und selbst
besten zu weihnachten
air france ist ein verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit
jetzt nicht die wahl hätte würde ich was
anderes essen das ir staubtrocken
wir nicht das worüber die daily mail
schreibt ja der stand heute kriegen wir
was besonderes
sowie luxus truthahn mit bratkartoffeln
das meiste wird wohl im abfall landen
das ist ein tag wie jeder andere für
mich und einer den ich von meiner knast
zeit im kalender abhaken kann wieder ein
jahren zwölf habe ich noch mindestens
mal sehen wie lange ich dann noch
bleiben muss
[Musik]
einige gefangene im garten hatten sich
noch nie etwas zuschulden kommen lassen
bevor sie wegen mordes verhaftet wurden
[Musik]
ein anderes wort für einen grausamen
menschen
könnte sagt ist sein
das passt auch zum nie als
lösungsbuchstaben
[Musik]
vor seiner verurteilung arbeitete david
für das britische
verteidigungsministerium
im gefängnis hat er angefangen
kunstgeschichte zu studieren
die kunst führt mich ein schöner ort als
diesen her
so kann ich einen moment lang alles um
mich herum vergessen
fühlen sie sich mit ihrer vorgeschichte
als außenseiter hier
das leben hat es mit mir im großen und
ganzen sehr gut gemeint warum kommt mir
meine tat auch irgendwie noch schlimmer
vor
die brauchst du deine handtasche
davids töchter ruf und sarah besuchen
ihren vater einmal im monat
[Musik]
seine haare sind kürzer
aber der gefängnis haarschnitt
geht's dir gut ja doch die war
weihnachten gut sehr schön
die psychologen sagten ich stelle
eigentlich kein risiko dar nur
beziehungen werden kritisch ich sagte
ich kann mir im moment gar keine neue
beziehung vorstellen aber das wäre dann
natürlich schwierig
die polizei stand vor der tür und
erklärte uns was passiert war
ich war geschockt ich konnte es einfach
nicht glauben ja mir ging es genauso ich
fragte sind sie sich sicher dass es mein
vater war und sie sagten ja er hat alles
gestanden
wie könnte ich so arrogant sein mir
selbst nicht zu verzeihen wenn andere
menschen dazu bereit sind das war ein
wichtiger schritt um aus dem loch heraus
zu kommen denn dass ich viel nachdem ich
ihre mutter ermordet hatte
[Musik]
als wir uns kennenlernten waren wir noch
recht jung wir haben geheiratet und
bekam zwei kinder
irgendwann waren die mädchen erwachsen
und zogen aus
plötzlich waren wir nur noch zu zweit
mit einer blüte regelrecht auf aus der
schüchternen frau wurde eine viel
selbstbewusstere person sie gingen
alleine aus und wollte neue leute
kennenlernen
eines tages sagte sie dass sie mich
nicht mehr liebt
sie wollte zwar noch den tisch mit mir
teilen aber nicht mehr das bett
weihnachten 2007 sagte sie sie hätte
besuch eingeladen
ich dachte es seine freundin aber wie
sich herausstellte war es ein mann
sie bat mich um geld ich wurde wütend
dass sie geld von mir wollte um sich mit
einem anderen mann zu vergnügen
sie sagte sie könne es kaum erwarten mit
ihrem neuen partner zusammen zu sein und
was für ein erbärmlicher man echt sei
da rastete ich aus ich konnte nicht mehr
klar denken
den meine blinden wut habe ich sie
erwürgt
[Musik]
wann wurde ihnen klar was sie getan
hatten
als sich die anspannung in meinen unter
armen fühlte
ich sage hoch und meine hände lagen um
mitteilers hals
da wurde mir klar dass sie tot war
ich rief die polizei und einen
krankenwagen
was haben sie gesagt ich sagte ich habe
meine frau getötet ich glaube ich habe
sie erwirkt die sagten ich solle nach
ihr sehen aber ich hätte den anblick
nicht ertragen
hätte ich sofort erste hilfe geleistet
würde sie vielleicht noch leben
[Musik]
viele leute verstehen nicht warum wir
ihm verziehen haben
und wie wir das geschafft haben aber für
mich sind es zwei unterschiedliche
menschen der david edwards der das getan
hat ist nicht mein vater das war ein
anderer der offensichtlich keine
kontrolle über sich hatte
so kann ich irgendwie damit umgehen
ihnen besuchen und ihm weiterhin in die
augen sehen
wenn man die person tötet die man liebt
trauert man doppelt einmal um die person
und dann weil man ihren tod selbst
verursacht hat in gewisser hinsicht
kriegt jeder mörder lebenslänglich weil
er jede sekunde jede minute und jede
stunde seines restlichen lebens mit
dieser tat leben muss
heute ist es genau sieben jahre her dass
ich mein freund gary getötet haben
denken sie noch oft an diesem tag
fast täglich
ich denke nicht nur heute daran aber
heute jährt sich eben dieser tag ich
denke fast täglich daran
ich habe bilder von gary im kopf zum
beispiel wie er neben mir im zug sitzt
oder wie wir mal mit dem boot einen tag
zum angeln rausgefahren sind aufs meer
er bekam einen sonnenbrand
aber nur auf der einen hälfte seines
gesichts ist mir ein rätsel wie das ging
aus als hätte er eine gesichtshälfte mit
roter farbe angepinselt und die andere
weiß gelassen
ich habe noch sein lachen immer nach
einem witz
mir geht es beschissen heute vor sieben
jahren habe ich die kontrolle verloren
abends um halb acht
[Musik]
er fehlt mir
ja danke
heute abend wird mein tattoo weiter
gestochen auf
den arm kommt eine meerjungfrau
das sind die schuppen wozu die
tätowierung
sobald die nadel in die haut sticht
fällt der ganze frust von mir ab
die farbe geht unter die haut ist blutet
und bleibt für immer
es ist befreiend es befreit den geist
[Musik]
heute ist einer der wichtigsten tage
meines lebens ich habe seit vier tagen
kaum geschlafen
vom mosaik monaten denke ich an nichts
anderes
wenn ein gefangener seiner
mindesthaftzeit verbüßt hat kann er
bewährung beantragen jason wurde vor
acht jahren wegen einer reihe von
gewalttätigen übergriffen verurteilt
darunter raub und eine messerattacke
heute versucht er zum dritten mal den
bewährungsausschuss davon zu überzeugen
dass von ihnen keine gefahr mehr ausgeht
heute geht es darum einzuschätzen wie
groß das risiko ist dass von ihnen
ausgeht die kernfrage lautet geben sie
nur lippenbekenntnisse ab oder haben sie
sich wirklich geändert
der mensch der ich heute bin hat mit den
menschen der ich bin meiner inhaftierung
war überhaupt nichts gemeinsam
damals war ich in einer gang wollte
respektiert werden und war kriminell
ich kannte nichts anderes
heute wünsche ich mir eine familie und
ein geregeltes leben
erzählen wir sagen viele wenn sie hier
vor uns sitzen ich will eine familie
einen job aber sagen sie uns doch bitte
was genau sich verändert hat
ich habe hier die finger von drogen
gelassen und mich nicht an kriminellen
aktivitäten beteiligt ich halte mich von
solchen leuten und situationen fern das
hätte ich früher nicht getan
dem bewährungsausschuss liegt jacksons
gefängnis akte vor einschließlich der
psychologischen berichte
während seiner haft hatte er eine reihe
von richterlichen anhörungen den konsum
juni 2009 verbale und körperliche
bedrohung und beleidigung
wie erklären sie diese vorfälle
ich habe noch einen langen weg vor mir
ich will nicht behaupten dass ich ein
völlig anderer mensch bin dass ich
meinem ideal bild entspreche denn das
tue ich nicht ich muss noch viel an mir
arbeiten
mit in die anhörung ist für heute
beendet wie sie wissen erfahren sie
unseren beschluss nicht sofort aber
innerhalb der nächsten zwei wochen ein
wesentlicher bestandteil eines jeden
urteils sollte sein dass man es
hinterfragt und überdenkt um am ende die
richtige entscheidung zu treffen
extreme im extremfall haben wir uns
geirrt und lassen jemanden frei der dann
ein schweres verbrechen begeht
[Musik]
in den letzten zehn jahren ist die
mordrate in großbritannien stabil
geblieben aber die anzahl von gefangenen
mit lebenslangen haftstrafen hat sich
auf fast 8000 verdoppelt größtenteils
weil sie heute sehr viel länger im
gefängnis bleiben als je zuvor denken
sie manchmal an flucht kommt schon mal
vor
hab ich pläne geschmiedet nein
da würde ich das tun
die meisten lebenslänglichen würden wohl
nicht mal abhauen wenn ihr hier das tor
offen stehen lassen
wenn ich ausbrecher einfach über den
zaun springen wird sofort jeder
briefkontakt überprüft jeder mit dem ich
telefoniert habe also die menschen die
mir am meisten am herzen liegen
ich könnte also meine kinder meine
familie und meine freunde niemals
wiedersehen
wie sinnlos ich wäre nicht frei nur auf
der anderen seite der mauer
einige der gefangenen kämen nicht mal im
traum auf die idee zu fliegen
hier drin hat man alles was man braucht
drei mahlzeiten am tag
ich habe sehr schön es ist sauber alles
super was will ich mehr
was glauben sie wie es zurzeit draußen
ist und
mögliche einen job zu kriegen ich bin
froh nicht da draußen zu sein ich warte
lieber bis sich alles beruhigt hat
2008 wurde lenz zusammen mit seinem
besten freund und seiner mutter
angeklagt wegen mordes an einem älteren
mann auf dessen ersparnisse sie es
abgesehen hatten
vor gericht hat meine mutter alle schuld
auf mich geschaut mensch wie boshaft
frauen sein können ich bin damals
aufgesprungen und habe versucht ihr voll
eine reinzuhauen im ernst warum weil sie
mir in ihrer aussage die schuld gegeben
hat die ist völlig krank im kopf sie
heute sich die augen aus dem kopf und
zeigte mit dem finger auf mich und sagte
dauernd er hat das alles getan
sie ist so ein mordprozess
langweilig ich bin fünf mal
eingeschlafen es hat natürlich nicht
gerade den besten eindruck gemacht aber
ich kann nichts dafür dieser typ von
staatsanwalt hat verdammt nochmal
stundenlangen von irgendwelchen
telefonverbindungen geschlossen wenn ich
ein gefühl als
sie zu 18 jahren verurteilt wurde bin
ich fast zusammengebrochen ich habe
nicht gehört oder so mir war einfach
kotzübel aber jetzt denke ich nicht mehr
darüber nach was soll's die zeit vergeht
wie im flug
jason da
der beschluss zu jason bewährungs antrag
ist eingetroffen ist er positiv könnte
er gar tree schon bald verlassen
der ausschuss ist überzeugt dass die
gefahr ausreichend reduziert ist um die
empfehlung auszusprechen die
haftbedingungen zu lockern
es geht nach hause
endlich
jason kommt in den offenen strafvollzug
ein wichtiger schritt richtung freiheit
dann kann ich endlich mein leben leben
ein erfülltes leben ich kann endlich all
meine pläne in die tat umsetzen
du hast die chance ich hatte die chance
großartig main
[Musik]
die erste kiste ist voll
sie wird in einem gefängnis mit geringen
sicherheitsstufe verlegt
ich habe aus diesem elend ab morgen bin
ich weg
ich habe mich gebessert jetzt sind die
mich los bin ziemlich angespannt all der
umzugsstress
dieser ort wird mir auch ein bisschen
fehlen ich hatte mich gut eingelebt
danke an die außenwelt macht mich schon
ein bisschen nervös ein schuss
tschüss
alles gute mein junge was auf dich auf
viel glück
[Musik]
dass wir raus erst weg genau das
ich sehe das so ich bin noch vier
weltmeisterschaften langen haft
ich will dich den jahren rechnen oder in
weihnachtsfesten ich will keine 18
weihnachtsfeste abwarten sondern vier
weltmeisterschaften fertig
[Musik]
der richter sagte ich wird im gefängnis
sterben und dann ist das so
er könnte mich auch gleich zu selbstmord
verurteilen nun wollen sie einen strick
oder ein messer
[Musik]
es vergeht kaum eine stunde in der ich
nicht über meine tat nachdenken
so etwas kann man nicht tun ohne sich
dafür zu hassen
auf nimmerwiedersehen hoffe ich im
besten sinne
ich glaube ich bin ein anständiger
mensch ich habe fehler gemacht sind wir
den gegner sticks auch echt große fehler
aber ich bin nicht anders als die leute
draußen
jedem kann so was passieren die leute
die gerade diese sendung sehen könnten
heute abend oder morgen abend nächste
woche oder nächstes jahr losziehen und
ein mord begehen